la première question vous avez vu donc
ces images dans les noms les autres pays
est ce qu'on pourra passer un été de ce
genre en france on va essayer la grève
depuis lundi dernier on a levé la
cession des 10 km ça veut dire qu'on a
beaucoup plus de trajets en france daté
en europe
ouais ce qu'on va essayer de faire c'est
un bel été je vais demander à la sncf de
faire des petits prix on aura cinq
millions de billets à moins de 39 euros
et pour les jeunes de moins de 12 ans et
ce sera ce sera 8 euros pour les billets
donc on va essayer de faire un bel été
sur le mode ferroviaire vous aviez
vraiment essayé voilà de retour réduire
pour tout le monde on a fait un bel été
les derniers en vérité on a vu 85 % du
trafic habituel d'accord et dernière
c'était plutôt pas mal déplacer en
france
ensuite ce qu'on essaye de faire c'est
qu'à la mi juin on puisse rouvrir les
vols internationaux notamment les vols
si les trafics par bateau mais notamment
les vols donc là on a une réunion
mercredi avec les ministres des
transports du g7 avec les américains
avec les japonais avec bref le g7 le jeu
scénique et donc vous allez donc on
essaie de leur donner
voilà on essaie de coordonner au mot sur
deux plans d'abord dire que c'est
réciproque si les français si les
américains viennent en france et en
europe
l'idée c'est quand même évidemment que
la réciproque soit vraie et puis on
essaie de se mettre de mettre en place
les bons outils
là on expérimente le travel passe et
c'est le fameux ipad sanitaire qui
permet de fluidifier les files
d'attentes dans les aéroports et puis
d'échanger des suffisamment on va aller
vers ça cet été il faudra de son travail
passe l'idée ce qu'on essaie de faire
c'est d'avoir quelque chose d'assez
simple donc en gros vous avez soit un
test pcr soit un certificat de
vaccination soit vous avez ulcos vide
vous en avez été guéri et donc vous
devez pouvoir assez rapidement
l'embarquement
on pouvait penser que cet été on va
pouvoir passer ses vacances en dehors de
l'europe
ou bien ça va être compliqué d'aller aux
états unis vous parlez des états unis
d'ailleurs moi je pense qu'on aura ce
qu'on va essayer de faire c'est d'avoir
les états unis avec du nord il contenait
corps et d'avoir tout l'europe le nord
de l'afrique le maghreb et je pense que
ça va être difficile pour la chine se
sont signature à tj hyper stricte 2-0
qu'ovide mais si on avait déjà on va
dire l'afrique l'europe et l'amérique du
nord ce serait plutôt pas mal
il faudra pas être vaccinés pour voyager
faudrait taxer victoire soit avant un
test pcr ce qu'on essaie de faire un don
il faut que tous les pays il accepte
mais l'idée
ça soit un test pcr soit un vaccin
le certificat de vaccination soit
effectivement avoir contracté le vide en
avoir été guérie donc avoir à tests
d'immunologie alors on va opposer
d'autres sections aux récentes qu'il ya
plein de questions bien entendu aussi
ils veulent partir en vacances même si
fabrice di vizio déjà ça c'est pas beau
et il y avait une question au ministre
le canada pas imposer une obligation
vaccinale un débat qu'on avait un modèle
un peu comme les comme israël donc ça
c'est un des grands débats qu'on a eue
au g7 sait ce que vaut catégoriser par
pays ou par individu je fais court mais
c'est un peu le sujet qu'on est avec eux
et par ailleurs il ya des pays qui n'ont
pas numériser leurs tests de vaccination
nous on l'a fait mais pas tous les pays
y compris des grands pays
la remarque si vous voulez bien la
remarque moi qui me vient monsieur le
ministre c'est que c'est vachement bien
de penser ou à l'infiniment grand
mais vous avez un problème beaucoup plus
pragmatique l infiniment petit est à
dire les déplacements quotidiens des
français parce qu'aujourd'hui riche
ministre moi j'ai quand même une
difficulté majeure c'est que vous
raisonnez finalement voyages
internationaux mais vous savez quand
même que le principal problème que nous
avons c'est qu'aujourd'hui depuis un an
les transports en commun français
transport en commun tout coup du
quotidien sont considérées comme un lieu
où on ne se contaminent pas et pardonnez
moi avec vous savez que c'est faux enfin
j'espère vous avez des passages de roues
se contamine peu et moins qu'ailleurs
féministes se comptent à l'une des deux
tests mais j'apprendrais moi mais je
reviens sur votre idée de passes annie
terre vous avez imposé des pénalités
avaient peu importe la légitimité pour
voyager pour les rassemblements de 1000
personnes à l'extérieur ou à l'intérieur
voudrait dépasser sanitaire mais le seul
endroit où c'est pas obligatoire c'est
dans le métro il y avait mille personnes
dans le métro
effectivement qu'on s'est rassemblée à
l'extérieur vous m'expliquez qu'on se
contaminent moins dans le métro qu'à
l'extérieur et qu'à l'extérieur on
n'allait pas sanitaires et pas dans le
métro par des matériaux l'argument de
bon sens à l'arrêt après moi je le
regarde la réalité des faits ça fait 1
quasiment un an et demi qu'on vit sous
convie tous les pays vivent sous
qu'ovide et tous les pays où les
transports en commun et donc tous ont
fait des études
donc quand on a regardé vraiment très
précisément ce qu'ils ont fait aux états
unis en angleterre au japon par tout
d'abord certains pays effectivement ont
mis des applications mais c'est plutôt
des pays qu'ils font
contrôle social qui contrôle un peu leur
population on n'a évidemment pas choisi
ce modèle là et ensuite on a
comparativement à d'autres lieux les
entreprises d'autres lieux on a plutôt
beaucoup moins de contamination dans les
transports ça s'explique par trois
choses d'abord les gens portent masquer
des transports c'est obligatoire depuis
le début mai les gens parlent peu dans
les transports et en général les gens
restent peu dans les transports donc
croiser peu de personnes et c est ce
assez consensuel dans toutes les études
du monde quelques quel que soit le pays
que vous preniez gilles verdez je me lis
on a tous en tête et vous aussi l'idée
de la liberté c'est à dire pouvoir faire
ce qu'on veut s'arrêter mais moi j'ai
une question concrète
est ce que en fait ça va mais pas être
l'été de toutes les restrictions est ce
que le pass annie terre va pas être
indispensable même pour se déplacer en
france et on entend parler de communes
qui veulent imposer des réservations en
ligne sur les plages est ce qu'en fait
ça va être l'été de toutes les
interdictions
moi c'est ma crainte c'est un sujet très
important je pense que cet été celle où
est un été de liberté là on part les
transports internationaux et il ya déjà
des restrictions et l'idée c'est de
pouvoir ouvrir un peu le monde
mais effectivement le faire en bon ordre
et en sécurité on n'a pas imposé de
passer du temps dans les transports on
n'a pas l'ambition de l'imposer pour cet
été on en avait que les français
puissent avec ce protocole sanitaire
partir et retrouver les leurs et passé
et passer du bon temps avec le plus de
liberté possible
on veut aussi se prémunir des effets de
reprise du virus à l'automne ou à la
rentrée je pense que tout le monde est
sur la même ligne ou longueur d'onde ce
sujet est-ce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
aussi qui dit est ce qu'il y aura assez
suffisamment d'avions et de trains
parce qu'il ya plein de gens qui vont
vouloir se déplacer est ce qu'il y aura
des droits d'édition des choses en plus
basse et leur sujet là on a beaucoup
réduit du fait du confinement on a on
avait quatre tgv sur 10 pour prendre un
exemple d'accord les week-ends point de
kuta sociaux on met en moyenne 8 trains
sur 10 et sur les grands axes
l'atlantique le sudes la bretagne mais
quasiment 100% des trains donc je vois
des trains à la sncf est prête
aujourd'hui juste pour donner une idée
on a à peu près 10% du trafic aérien
mondial en europe qui sanctionne donc
c'est très très peu mais évidemment les
compagnies aériennes vont remettre des
avions air france entamé voilà qui va
faire du shopping en or en examen il ya
beaucoup de gens qui parlent du grand
rodez joue comme ça le port du masque à
l'extérieur qui ne serait plus
obligatoire cet été est ce que ça va
être le cas
ouais mais bon moi je peux parler pour
mes collègues s'est pas directement
sujet moi je l'espère à titre à titre
personnel on voit déjà
ta mère sur certaines zones et complet
française qui prennent les arrêter pour
relâcher un peu cette pression là et je
crois que monsieur fisher s'est exprimé
en disant que l'espérer au cours de
l'été ou en tout cas d'ici à la fin de
l'été nous puissions relâcher les
masques dans des espaces publics les
plus larges
donc ça c'est des discussions qu'on a
toutes les semaines en conseil de
défense
on a la chance on a la chance d'avoir le
porte parole du gouvernement après canal
bernard montiel à neuf tableaux voulu
vous avez une question oui je crois que
le vrai problème qui va se poser c'est
l'harmonisation
écoutez moi je pense que le vrai
problème et on tient citoyen normal
c'est beau fils et pas mal de choses et
je peux vous dire je suis surtout un
sétois d'accès pas mal de chose
d'anormal je veux dire c'est qu'il y
aura un problème d'harmonisation avec
les autres pays
c'est vrai alors alors alors si c'est
une question l'harmonisation et qu'ils
ont accueilli récemment les pays
européens mais du coup parce que ça
c'est pas fait mais la bascule de
l'intervention est ce que vous pouvez
faire une question pour monsieur minutes
mais c'est une affirmation puisque à
laquelle il va répondre c'est une vraie
vision je veux pas pour monsieur
division l'occasion alors question
monsieur djebbari ce que je sais c'est
on n'a déjà pas le conseil des ministres
mercredi de ben wallace
bonne question évidemment on essaie de
faire en sorte que à l'échelle
européenne on soit évidemment très
coordonné c'est tout le sujet du pass
anita la directive s'est juré t et après
c'est les grands blocs
ils étaient les grands blocs l'amérique
du nord etats unis le canada le japon
etc
mais là on sait qu'on ne pourra pas tout
ouvrir tout ce qu'il a il ya des pays
qui ont vu qu'ils vont nous imposer des
quarantaines donc imaginer vacances de
merde qu'on va passer ses attachements
intéressant c'est justement pour ça
voilà c'est juste en espagne en fait
tous les pays qui n'ont pas encore
complètement numériser leurs systèmes et
c'est justement pour ça qu'on a ces
discussions au plus haut niveau pour
dire et si on fait en sorte de ne pas
voir les quarantaine et si on veut
fonctionner avec voilà il protocole les
tests et le vaccin il va pas vous
comprendre
le compagnie aérienne parce que elle
elle vous sont pas forcément toutes
soumises entre guillemets donc est-ce
que vous avez un point d'ancrage sur ls
parce que parfois on a vu que certaines
faisait n'en faisait qu'à leur tête et y
compris malienne quand le gouvernement
l'heure de donner un ordre de chemin eh
bien parfois certaines compagnies
aériennes notamment air france de
décider
oui ou non le test pas le test et c'est
bien justement humilité la tue on a eu 1
kg bernard mes cadets des heures et les
compagnies qu'on a rappelés à l'ordre
quelques unes qui respectait pas les
règles et les protocoles donc sans les a
mises en demeure on a suspendu des vols
dakar ethiopian pendant trois jours fin
décembre de mémoire suspension de bol ça
fait toujours mal aux compagnies
aériennes
hélas ce qu'on a vu c'est qu'on avait
des contournements en avait des
personnes qui passaient par mexico par
dubaï par madrid pour rentrer en france
donc ça on a renforcé depuis la semaine
dernière les contrôles cette semaine
aussi en europe
donc on essaie vraiment de d'être
étanche ce n'est pas toujours simple
stevie mènent parfois mais alors moi
monsieur le ministre cet été je serai au
théâtre mais j'ai deux questions mais
c'est ce qu'il nous aimait bien alors je
sais que tu transportes aurait dit deux
mandats légaux
malheureusement je n'ai pas accès en
revanche vous êtes face à moi ya deux
questions les jeunes ils sont pas tous
vaccinés cet été et ce qu'ils vont
pouvoir venir nous voir au théâtre et
nous les comédiens
il va tenter de vacciner
le conseil des ministres c'est un peu
non mais l'idée c'est un peu la
philosophie c'est celle que j'ai
expliqué c'est de dire que pour rentrer
dans un certain nombre de lieux et
compris les transports vous avez soit un
test pcr
soit vous avez vacciner c'est un peu ça
le le sujet donc évidemment tout le
monde ne sera pas vaccinés au cours de
l'été d'ailleurs personne dans le monde
aucun pays n'aura sont partis assez peu
près se vacciner d'ailleurs dans un pays
vous ne pouvez pas avoir 100 % de
population vaccinée des gens qui ne sont
pas compatibles avec les vaccins etc
donc il essaie ça c'est d'avoir un
protocole pour que vous soyez soit
titulaire d'un certificat de vaccination
soit que vous y êtes espèces et ak steel
isabelle 100e faisait juste cette
question pour faire sa promo benjamin
castaldi
moi j'ai mes questions on sait que
l'objectif c'est tout avec signer et
d'en avoir le plus possible
pourquoi on n'a pas des transports pour
être une fête de carotte pour encourager
les français à justement à l'essai avec
senna alors ce serait un petit peu
d'escrimé les toits mais serait plutôt
donné 25 battre on en a parlé hier par
exemple d'encourager les gens à vacciner
pour avoir accès à tous les transports
lorsque de ça que c'est un peu c'est un
peu le cas les déplacer ou qui doivent
se déplacer aujourd'hui font détester
ces machinations
mais ce qui est sûr c'est sympa prix
c'est juste illégal de faire ça l'accès
aux services essentiels
le règlement le règlement sur le passage
du ter européen que j'ai lu ce matin
vous le précise pierre ce serait
totalement illégal de faire ça parce que
vous ne pouvez pas subordonnée l'accès à
des services publics essentiels à une
condition de santé y compris la
vaccination
c'est pour ça que j'ai expliquées
évidemment que l'idée c'était pas dehors
pas de forcer à vacciner tout le monde
d'inciter au hédas d'inciter l'incité
c'est évidemment bien d'ailleurs les
français veulent se faire vacciner et
vous pouvez les français majoritairement
sont aujourd'hui supporters du pass
sanitaires pour pouvoir retrouver leur
liberté
alors monsieur le ministre les français
supporteurs du pas statutaire week en c
b 65 ans âge
franchement je suis un vieux baroudeur
des libertés publiques
c'est vrai mais juste éviter de prendre
les français pour des imbéciles ce
serait pas mal juste ou là je veux dire
se passe à l'idée qu'on vienne pas me
dire monsieur le ministre je comprends
parfaitement fassiez de la politique
c'est votre job
le mien c'est le principe du réel il
venait pas dire aujourd'hui qui
effectivement les français sont
favorables à une restriction de leur
liberté
non mais c'est toujours un équilibre le
principe du réel c'est que si vous
voulez pas avoir de vaccination vous
vous terrer chez vous fermer les
frontières et c'est ce que font nos deux
pays et des pays qui ont choisi ce
régime super stricte de contrôle des
populations à la peau le coup vous
n'avez pas de liberté du tout on essaie
de préserver l'activité économique de
préserver les libertés et ne pas
reprendre le feu à la santé allah en
septembre avec 1 mais si je prends un
billet aujourd'hui mais que tour ferme
demain à cause d'un variant ou autres ce
qu'on sera remboursé c'est annulable
échangeables jusqu'au jour avant le
départ donc ça doit rassurer aussi un
peu les assurés qui veut l'accord donc
on voit là c'était la même citation
chine non c'était une autre caisse alors
isabelle une question vous n'avez pas
cité l'amérique du sud on vous en avait
parlé trois fois est ce que c'est parce
que le brésil pose un problème
insurmontable à l'heure actuelle bonnes
questions d'isabelle ces essais les
bonnes réponses du coup dans la question
un plan la question puisque
effectivement le brésil l'inde le chili
l'argentine sont des zones qui sont très
touchés donc la main aujourd'hui et très
touchés avec des campagnes de
vaccination qui avance quand même assez
investement donc pour le coup voilà
toute la cordillère des andes
ça vient de partir en vacances mais on
revient on revient par exemple où vous
avez le cas de la tunisie en ce moment
il ya un questionnement ou ornés de
vacances comment ça se passe quand les
héros avec la tunisie s'te plaît non
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de questions qui
se posent il ya plein de gens qui ont
pris des billets entre aussi à 5400
personnes qui part du 5 au 29 janvier
il y aura une décision qui sera prise le
15 juin donc en plein milieu de leurs
vacances ils ont besoin de savoir
comment ça se passe pour leur retour la
france je crois que travaille chez pacha
pompey derrière ça alors là tu me dis-je
un départ à 13 45
[Rires]
gyneco le pire c'est que ça finit par
ressembler à ça mon bureau mais ça
aurait eu l'habitude de ça parce que ça
nous est déjà arrivé de poser des
restrictions pendant les vacances et des
vidéos qu'on a toujours permis aux
ressortissants français aurait un sens
elle rentre c'est encore d'ailleurs le
cas nous a un peu forcé la main sur les
ressortissants à l'étranger a donc c'est
très bien très bien qu'ils aient forcé
d'accord vous voulez l'avait déjà fallu
passer par le juge
bon on l'avait déjà fait c'est la
démocratie s'est fait partie des bruines
homme a faim on avait toujours fait ça
quand on a eu le premier confinement on
a fait revenir de mémoire plus de deux
cent mille français litres éparpillés de
par le monde le conseil est à vous a
condamné pour ce qui concerne les
ressortissants français de l'étranger
qui étaient bloqués à l'étranger
venez pas dire qu'effectivement ça s'est
toujours fait mais dans les faits a dû
forcer l'état s'en mêle à 10 a réussi à
fâcher le conseil d'un dans les faits
tous les français qui on voulait rentrer
ont toujours pu le faire dans des délais
qui sont qui sont compatibles cohérent
avec jean baptisé marry est-ce que cet
été vous êtes confieront les français
pourront partir facilement en europe
vous avez dit en amérique du nord a
priori voilà donc ça c'est en france
bien entendu ils vont pouvoir se
déplacer normalement confiance je suis
pas mais volontaire c'est sûr et donc on
va tout faire on va mettre tout en
oeuvre de manière à ce que ce soit
possible
d'accord j'ai comme un problème monsieur
ministre excusez moi mais avec le
metteur en scène entre les mêmes juillet
mme seillé des français qui partiront
pas en vacances et qui vont continuer
d'aller travailler et je reviens à ma
question de bazin pardonnez moi parce
que tout le monde pense aux vacances
mais moi je pense aux gens qui bossent
pour le coup et donc il ya une
particularité je comprends pas si je
comprends bien dans les protocoles
sanitaires y compris dans les musées ou
a priori repas tellement gueuler pas
tellement
charles a fait on va rester en silence
où on va être masqué nous avons un
protocole sanitaire de 1 pour 4 mètres
carrés c'est ce qui semble se dessiner
vous pouvez nous expliquer par quel
mystère est ce que on est un pur 4
mètres carrés dans les musées mais on
est quatre par mètre carré dans le métro
et quelles sont les mesures de sécurité
à la dernière rétrograde et on va vous
expliquer comment on a construit le
protocole sanitaire
quand on a eu le premier confinement on
a regardé ce que j'ai tous les autres
pays on a essayé de faire en sorte qu'on
a d'abord le protocole sanitaire le plus
efficace possible dans les transports
c'est à dire permettre aux gens de se
déplacer et compris pour leur transport
du quotidien permettent
aux gens de prendre un peu de repos et
d'aller en vacances quand c'était
possible et minimisé le risque sanitaire
c'est ce qu'on a fait c'est le modèle
français je crois qu'ils marchent plutôt
bien côté transports vous êtes satisfait
de la réponse
non non